Let's see if we can find it
the face of this parallelogram.
I also recommend that you pause the video
and see if you can find it.
Okay, we just have to remember,
that the face of the parallelogram
will be just the foundation -
let me do it in a different color -
will be the basis of the parallelogram,
I want to write it in a different color,
so let me write:
the base of the parallelogram
at its height,
at the height of the parallelogram.
The face is equal to the height base.
What we can accept for
the basis of this parallelogram?
Well, we can assume it will be one of those countries.
So we can get out of here,
and I could say ...
I could accept this country as the basis.
What is the length of the base?
We just go in the vertical direction.
We go from five to five,
to equal to minus seven,
so it has a length of 12.
We have five above the x axis and seven below the x axis,
total 12.
Or you can count them:
One two three four five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten, 11, 12.
So this is the foundation
and we can say that the base is equal to 12.
Now what can we look like height?
Well we can look at this part
here is the height.
And how much will it be?
Well, it seems very clear,
that the height is four.
This can be a little unpredictable,
because usually when talking about height,
we are accustomed to thinking how high something is given,
but you can imagine spinning this way,
that the base lies horizontally
and then the height will be height
in the traditional meaning of the word.
But we can say that h equals four
and it's now very easy.
The face will be equal to 12,
the length of the base along the height,
four,
yes, four,
which is clear that it is 48.
48 - say -
48 square units.